To use the rational zero theorem, we first need to find all the factors of
negative 164 and positive 1. Well, 1 is easy. We just have 1 and negative 1.
There are a few more for negative 164. We have 1, 2, 4, 41, 82, 164 and the
negative versions of all of those numbers. Now that we have two sets of
factors, all we need to do is take one factor from this batch and divide it by
one of the factors from over here. Now, since all the factors on this right,
that we are going to be dividing by, are just 1 and negative 1, the only ratios
you would end up with are all of the numbers over here. So, there we go, we
have the list we were looking for. Even though this is still a lot of numbers,
it's way fewer than the infinite number we were thinking about before, when we
had no idea what the roots were.